la parole est à monsieur thierry mariani
monsieur le monsieur le premier ministre
la saison des molières approche et je
crois qu'en matière de distinction
théâtrale avec un scénario bien ficelé
comme celui que nous présente votre
gouvernement dérobant dix permanents des
rebondissements permanents
c'est un molière du meilleur scénario
que méritent votre gouvernement
en effet chaque jour chaque jour une
nouvelle annonce chaque jour un ministre
progressiste et compris aux mesures
chaque jour des suggestions
regardons les deux derniers actes
al'approche d'une renégociation des
règles d'indemnisation du chômage
madame elle comrie et monsieur sapin
nous parle de dégressivité des
allocations chômage actes précédents à
davos
emmanuel macron annoncé la fin des 35
heures grâce au projet de réforme du
temps de travail et en moins de temps
qu'il faut pour le dire
ces propositions qui anime le débat qui
anime la presse sont immédiatement
enterrées
regardez par exemple le rapport badinter
qui a littéralement enterré la réforme
du droit du travail
alors monsieur le premier ministre les
annonces de vos ministres ont démenti
les propositions de l'opposition reste à
ce jour sans suite je pense par exemple
à celle faite par les régions qui
demande à prendre en charge
l'accompagnement de la recherche
d'emploi bref au final notre pays
détient vous le savez un triste record
trois millions cinq cent
quatre-vingt-dix mille chômeurs alors
que la plupart des pays européens voient
leur chômage reculer en france vous le
savez la courbe est loin de s'inverser
ma question est donc simple
au delà des effets d'annoncé des coûts
de communication des propositions peu
orthodoxes de certains ministres la
comédie jouée par votre gouvernement
laisse les français de marbre que faites
vous réellement pour lutter contre le
chômage
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
thierry mariani vous avez raison nous
vivons depuis de nombreuses années avec
un chômage à un niveau insupportable je
marque et vous le savez par une grande
précarité pas un chômage de longue durée
notamment des chômeurs peu qualifiés et
nous devons nous attaquer pleinement à
ce défi considérable pour notre société
je sais bien que tout ce qui a été fait
par le passé a été parfait et que ce que
chacun propose pour l'avenir est
particulièrement clair
mais au-delà de ces notations
ce qui m'importe ce qui importe au
gouvernement et au président la
république c'est l'engagement pour
l'emploi et contre le chômage
les partenaires sociaux ont une
responsabilité notamment dans le cadre
de la négociation de l'unedic et le
gouvernement invite tout simplement
chacun à prendre pleinement ses
responsabilités à tout faire pour
réduire le déficit de l'unedic et à tout
faire pour permettre le retour à
l'emploi c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui de
la responsabilité des partenaires
sociaux et la ministre du travail l'a
parfaitement rappelé si par malheur
cette négociation n'aboutissait pas le
gouvernement l'état prendrait pleinement
ses responsabilités
nous avons rencontré ce matin avec
plusieurs membres du gouvernement
d'abord à matignon et ensuite l'occasion
d'un déjeuner à l'elysée
nous avons rencontré l'ensemble des
présidents de région et je me suis
exprimé juste avant de venir ici à
l'assemblée nationale avec le président
des régions de france
ce philippe richert sur le fait que nous
étions en train d'élaborer pour les
prochains jours pour les prochaines
semaines un document conjoint qui donne
davantage de responsabilités aux régions
et dans le cadre des lois actuelles
c'est-à-dire de la luano devoir s'il
faut aller plus loin dans le cadre d'une
nouvelle législation qui permette aux
régions d'assumer et d'assurer
pleinement leurs responsabilités dans le
domaine du développement
économique de la formation de
l'accompagnement des chômeurs et de
l'apprentissage et j'ai dis encore une
fois que nous devions être à l'écouté de
l'ensemble des régions car au delà des
couleurs politiques
nous avions une responsabilité c'est de
tout faire pour le chômage
alors monsieur le député au delà des
phrases au delà des commentaires
au delà du cinéma moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est la réalité
c'est l'engagement de tous c'est
d'entendre les messages et les
présidents des régions l'ont
parfaitement entendu des électeurs etc
le tout faire pour nous engager dans
cette bataille pour l'emploi